Ще зовсім недавно "Північний потік-2" здавався приреченим.
Було лише цікаво, що потопить проєкт раніше -
санкції США чи якщо Зелені увійдуть у новий уряд Німеччини після виборів до Бундестагу у вересні.
І ось американського тиску на трубу, схоже, вже немає.
Спершу адміністрація Байдена, після приходу до влади у січні цього року, не відмовлялася від вимог припинити будівництво.
Президент Байден вже дуже давно чітко висловив свою думку, що "Північний потік-2" - це погана ідея,
і я повторив цю думку безпосередньо міністру закордонних справ ФРН Гайко Маасу.
І я також дав чітко зрозуміти, що фірми, залучені у будівництво газогону, ризикують отримати санкції США.
Цей трубопровід розділяє Європу, піддає Україну та Центральну Європу російським маніпуляціям і примусу.
Це суперечить власним цілям Європи щодо енергетичної безпеки.
Таку позицію Блінкен висловлював буквально ще навесні.
А нині держсекретар США стверджує, що завершення "Північного потоку-2" - це вже "доконаний факт"
і нові санкції не вплинули б на фізичне завершення добудови труби.
Я був проти "Північного потоку-2" від самого початку, але до мого вступу на посаду він був вже майже завершений.
І запроваджувати санкції зараз було б контрпродуктивно з точки зору наших європейських відносин.
При цьому остаточно знімати свою блокаду Вашингтон не поспішає.
Мовляв, рішення поки не запроваджувати санкції проти компанії Nord Stream 2 AG та її директора може бути переглянуто.
На думку багатьох оглядачів, такі дії США - ознака того, що Вашингтон веде пошук компромісу з Берліном і Москвою,
при цьому тримаючи Кремль у підвішеному стані з постійною загрозою санкцій.
В останні місяці компанія Nord Stream 2 AG намагалася добудувати газопроводу без зайвого шуму,
щоб не дратувати американців, які останнім часом вже менше прагнуть ввести санкції проти проєкту.
Кілька днів тому на економічному форумі в Петербурзі президент Росії Володимир Путін заявив,
що прокладка першої нитки газогону повністю завершена.
Дві труби підійшли одна до одної. Тепер з двох боків потрібно припідняти ці труби:
ту, яка прийшла з німецького берега і з російського берега. Зварити їх і все. На це днів 10, мабуть, знадобиться.
Путін переконує, що перша нитка газогону практично готова до прокачування газу.
Чи так це насправді? DW звернулася до компанії Nord Stream 2 AG.
Її представник Штеффен Еберт запевняє, що так.
Водночас, опитані DW експерти стверджують, що не все так просто і швидко.
Ще належить виконати чимало роботи, перш ніж трубопровід справді введуть в експлуатацію.
Для того, щоб підняти вже прокладену з Німеччини ділянку та з’єднати її з ділянкою, яка прийшла з данської зони,
потрібно приблизно три тижні, згідно з технічними умовами.
Треба буде ще проводити випробування, сертифікувати.
Тож казати про те, що завтра по трубі можна пустити газ і розпочати поставки до Німеччини, було б перебільшенням.
На думку багатьох політологів та оглядачів, Путін зробив таку самовпевнену заяву з огляду на зустріч
з американським президентом, яка планується 16 червня у Женеві.
Путін хотів використати петербурзький економічний форум, аби дати зрозуміти:
американські санкції не зможуть зупинити цей проєкт.
А тим більше зараз, оскільки нібито вже завершено будівництво першої нитки газогону.
Це було політичне послання - дати зрозуміти, що ми, мовляв, у цілі.
Як мінімум, щодо першої нитки. І нас ніщо не зупинить.
Путін також заявив, що Москва готова і в майбутньому, після закінчення дії транзитного договору з Києвом у 2024 році,
прокачувати газ через газотранспортну систему України за умови - цитата - "доброї волі з боку українських партнерів".
На думку оглядачів, це натяк на бартер: гроші від транзиту газу територією України
в обмін на вплив Кремля на політику в Україні. Позиція ж уряду Німеччини - незмінна.
Президент України Володимир Зеленський вважає "Північний потік-2" справжньою зброєю в руках Росії.
Він каже, що переконував Вашингтон не відмовлятися від санкцій проти цього газогону.
Втім, Байден вирішив не шкодити відносинам з Берліном, який активно відстоює добудову труби.
Колишня німецька депутатка Європарламенту від Зелених Ребекка Гармс теж критикує дії уряду Меркель.
Я вважаю особливо кричущим те, що Німеччина не може, продовжуючи реалізацію проєкту "Північний потік-2",
казати, що вона виступає за український суверенітет.
Грошима за російський природний газ вона підсилює оборонний бюджет Росії,
а водночас не може нічого зробити задля посилення обороноздатності України.
Термін завершення будівництва "Північного потоку-2" вже не раз переносився.
Спершу газопровід планували здати в експлуатацію ще в грудні 19-го року.
Актуальна орієнтовна дата - четвертий квартал нинішнього року.
Але 26 вересня в Німеччині мають відбутися вибори до Бундестагу, які можуть призвести до зміни влади, зважаючи на популярність Зелених.
Тож будь-яке зволікання може стати для проєкту фатальним, вважає Ґергард Манґотт.
Важливий орієнтир для долі "Північного потоку-2" - це зміна канцлера в Німеччині.
Адже якщо Зелені увійдуть до уряду ФРН або їхню партію представлятиме навіть майбутня канцлерка,
то перспективи у "Північного потоку-2" не дуже райдужні.
Адже Зелені рішуче виступають проти цього проєкту.
Навіть якщо Зелені просто увійдуть до складу уряду, все одно це поставить завершення проєкту під сумнів.
Це означає, що кожен тиждень, який втрачає "Північний потік-2", наближає проєкт до епохи "після Меркель".
А для "Північного потоку-2" в цьому полягає небезпека.
За Паризькою угодою Німеччина зобов'язалася стати до 2050 року кліматично нейтральною.
Уряд Анґели Меркель на час переходу від брудної теплової енергетики до екологічно чистих джерел енергії зробив ставку на природний газ.
Тож, поступову відмову від вугільних електростанцій планують компенсувати, серед іншого, збільшенням поставок газу з Росії.